voilà des français éprouvés par ses
longues semaines de confinement quel
effet psychique et psychologique cette
épreuve at elle sur chacun de nous qu at
elle changé aussi dans les relations que
nous entretenons les uns avec les autres
et puis on vient d'entendre des
critiques contre le gouvernement contre
le système est ce que les pies d'élite
que le 19 aura des conséquences sociales
et politiques si oui lesquelles c'est
avec toutes ces questions que nous
laisse ce film retour au salon de
frédéric jacob l'efs et pour approfondir
à présent j'accueille sur ce plateau
catherine tourette surgissent bonjour
vos chiens cette psychologue professeur
des universités à sorbonne universités
avec nous également paul cassia bonjour
jour professeur de droit à l'université
paris 1 panthéon sorbonne avec nous
également fabienne martin jugea bon jour
vous êtes professeur des universités
chercheuse en communication corporelle
et émotionnel à l'université grenoble
alpes
et puis nous avons le plaisir également
d'être en ligne avec jean viard bonjour
bonjour sociologue directeur de
recherche associé au cevipof le centre
d'etudes politiques de sciences po et du
cnrs alors je vais recommencer tout
simplement par ces images et surtout ces
témoignages qu'on vient d'entendre
peut-être par vous paul cassia qu'est-ce
qui vous marquent très spontanément
qu'est ce que ces conversations souligne
de l'expérience que chacun de nous a
vécu moi je me retrouve dans beaucoup de
ces témoignages je vous retrouve déjà
dans la chanson de jean ferrat ma france
avec cet appel à la liberté au delà des
frontières françaises et qui fait
presque un peu de mal à être écouté en
cette période où le confinement et
répétitif quel modèle donne nous
aujourd'hui nous étions le pays de la
déclaration de 1789
c'est ce qui ressort de la chanson est
maintenant que sommes nous devenus le
pays du confinement dur confinement du
rheu confinement ce qui aussi m'a
interpellé dans ces témoignages c'est là
cette dame qui dit pourvu que le monde
d'après ne soit pas exactement même que
le monde d'avant c'est l'histoire que ça
c'est l'espoir mais maintenant avec un
an de recul là j'ai l'impression qu'en
fait rien n'a changé et c'est un peu
inquiétant
il nous plonge vraiment dans la tête des
français ce documentaire catherine
toiture jce
qu'est ce qui finalement vous apprenez
ou qu'est ce qui vient confirmer
certaines intuitions que vous aviez
avant d'avoir vu ce film
oui en fait il est il documente
parfaitement les confire même les l'a
pas puisque sociale mais il ya des
choses très très fort très simple quoi
j'ai pas bougé et là par exemple on voit
que la personne qui dit j'ai pas bougé
comment vie psychique et vie physique
c'est à dire le fait de ne plus pouvoir
bouger au niveau moteur eh bien ça
plonge dans une certaine sidération
ce qu'on voit aussi ses cse papotage ce
ce qu'a fait finalement du
rétablissement ce salon ou via raconter
c'est à dire la mise en récit pour
passer l'épreuve
et ça ça montre bien parce que moi j'ai
fait aussi des écoutes
après le déconfinement et bien qu'il ya
un besoin de se raconter de dire de dire
l'épreuve
et puis de dire par où on est passé ça
montre aussi les mini institutions c'est
à dire un salon de coiffure
c'est un espace de socialisation un
rituel de socialisation n'y a pas de
café donc il ya un salon de coiffure
donc il ya plein de choses il ya un
parti pris du côté de la tendresse de
l'affection il ya une inquiétude pour
soi pour autrui est facile et il ya
plein de petit comme ça un invariant
dans le film qui sont extrêmement
intéressants
jean viard pour les sociologues le fait
de plonger comme ça dans la tête des
français d'aller regarder d'aller lise
entendre surtout ça confirme sa infirme
des des choses qu'on observe avec les
outils de la sociologie mais oui c'est
si nous les on a tous réfléchi
finalement de pan dans les dents et demi
bien sûr on a vécu des contraintes et
cetera mais en même temps je crois qu'on
a rarement pourtant réfléchit on s'est
auto rarement autant parler dans les
couples il ya aussi des coups violents
mais l'essentiel des coupes quand même
grâce à dieu sont pas violents etc
c'est des choses qu'on ne dit pas assez
si vous voulez et moi je pense que je
dis pas que le monde d'après sera
différent mais je pense qu'on vit une
expérience traumatique certainement mais
après on a envie de par leurs chauffeurs
pourraient donc c'est ça qui m'a amené
vous voulez ses caisses qu'au fond on
tire de sa et pour le dire autrement je
dirai comment on passe de la vécu intime
de la plaque de la tragédie l événement
historique qu'on est en train de muer en
fil rouge de notre émission jean viard
c'est très bien on va on va évidemment
parler de tous ces sujets là peut-être
quand même attardons nous parce qu'il ya
des mots qu'on était
prononcer notamment sur le mot de
sidération fabienne martin juché à vous
c'est aussi ce que vous ressortent de ce
ce que vous retirer de ce film vous
voyez des français sidéré un peu
estomaqué par ce qui leur est arrivé
oui je crois qu'il ya eu un vrai choc
un choc physique avant d'être un choc
psychologique dont rêveraient d'être
empêché corporellement abandonné on
parle de deux prisons à une sorte
d'isolement sensorielle et finalement ce
choc je trouve qu'il a révélé quelque
chose qui me semble essentielle qui est
que le travail le le plaisir de vivre et
c'est d'abord une expérience corporelle
mais qui est une expérience vers
l'extériorité mais également vers
l'intériorité
quand quelqu'un raconte finalement qu'il
a sorti ses photos la nostalgie du de
l'enfance d'un seul coup reprendre du
plaisir à regarder des oiseaux donc
c'était aussi l'occasion redécouvrir
voilà l'inutile et que notre relation
corporelle au monde elle est loin d'être
et que l'on dira secondaire elle les
primes brutes prix maurice et le c de la
place le socle fondateur de nos
socialité et on a attaqué ce sac
fondateur c'est intéressant parce que
vous êtes deux à avoir parlé de deux
mots qu'on retrouve dans le documentaire
effectivement c'est le mot liberté est
le mot prison
d'ailleurs qu'on regarde un extrait qui
dans lequel veut finalement un des
personnages add des propos un peu
contradictoires sur le sujet regardez
puis on va en parler après me suis levé
quand j'avais envie de me lever je me
suis couché quand j'avais envie de me
coucher
je me suis laissé vivre comme si j'étais
en vacances
c'était une belle expérience comme si on
était en prison mais sa propre prison
j'estime que c'est comme ça en prison
ils ont la télé ils ont à manger à boire
les toilettes se laver puis voilà il dit
à la fois c'est la liberté totale et
puis c'est comme si j'étais en prison et
finalement il a l'air de trouver ça
confortable est-ce que c'est
complètement normal catherine toiture
lice alors normal on va éviter tous ces
mots là mais en tout cas là ces
personnes qui parlent en tant que soit
avec soi c'est à dire qu'ils sont qui se
réfère à elle même mais en fait dans le
film ce qu'on va voir parce que c'est
quand même une question qu'on peut se
poser qu'est ce qui fait que les gens en
tenue
ce qui fait que les gens ont tenu en
tout cas au niveau psychique comme si
quelque chose c'est le relationnel
c'est à dire pourquoi on vit pourquoi on
survit on vit pour autrui et dans le
film on voit bien d'ailleurs on vit pour
autrui et du coup on s'inquiète pour
autrui la petite fille son anniversaire
les les intra générationnelle
intergénérationnel et ça c'est important
dans le film c'est d'un côté on peut se
le symptôme ce serait se sentir tout
seul comme en prison et le sauvetage ça
serait c'est le relationnel qui tissu
social on a l'impression janvier
notamment dans cet extrait là c'est
assez frappant que finalement on peut y
trouver son compte à cette situation
très contrainte qu'on s'adapte à tous
vas y que vaille
bien sûr alors à tout le monde alors
c'est vrai comme on était sidéré parce
que on a tous pensé qu'on pouvait un
jour aller en prison je sais pas c'est
une connerie un accident mais être
enfermés chez nous vraiment je crois
qu'on n'y avais jamais pensé c'était une
idée trop bleus n'avaient jamais eu bon
et dont je pense qu'il ya des gens qui
ont été heureux que j'aime oublier en
plus que quand même 65 % des français
ont un jardin
donc il faut se représenter si vous
n'êtes tout le monde n'habite pas dans
une tour sans terrasse et sans jardin
donc il ya ça aussi c'est extrêmement
différents et même les gens qui habitent
en ville y en a pas mais près d'un
million conquis tele2 france pour les
dans leur résidence secondaire ou dans
leur famille donc c'est pour ça que le
tour n'a pas tous vécu la même excuse
mais moi je voudrais qu'on dise une
chose il faut dire merci internet et
merci amazon c'est peut-être pas très
politiquement correct de dire ça vous
rendez compte y aurait pas eu internet
ce que ça aurait été d'être enfermé est
ce que dans l'extrait convient de voir
juste après et dit oh là là j'ai
organisé des apéritifs avec 50 60
personnes connectées
voilà c'est notamment ce qu'on voit dans
ce film je voudrais peut-être
une question sur 7 sur cette
contradiction liberté prisons là dessus
vous entendre vous paul cassia parce que
c'est vous qui parlez de la liberté tout
à l'heure et du fait que on a peut-être
un peu reculé quand même pendant cette
période de ce point de vue là on a
énormément reculé on a reculé d'une
manière inouïe oralité y avait déjà eu
un précédent
c'était celui de l'état d'urgence
sécuritaire qui a été mise en oeuvre de
2015 à 2017 après les attentats des
travaux là quand même
c'était au niveau micro individuel il y
avait quelques assignation à résidence
quelques assignation à domicile des
personnes qui se sont trouvées dans la
même situation que nous à peu près c'est
à dire être confiné 12 heures par jour à
leur domicile et ce qui s'est passé avec
le grand confinement de mars 2020 c'est
que nous avons toutes et tous étaient
confinés à l'échelle industrielle si
j'ose dire
et c'était d'autant plus inattendu qui
il faut le rappeler que le 6 mars encore
le président de la république aller au
théâtre nous inciter à faire preuve de
bon sens et à nous déplacer et que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale uzi
qu'il était hors de question de fermer
les écoles d'où le choc du confinement
auquel on ne s'attendait pas à ce choc
qui s'est doublée pour moi je risque
d'un choc
je veux dire juridique puisque c'était
une mesure qui est absolument
inenvisageable en circonstance non
exceptionnel sacré tout cela on n'a pas
un tout petit peu de l'immobilité du un
ralentissement quelqu'un disait voilà
c'est comme piler sur l'autoroute
au fond ce ralentissement qu'est ce
qu'il a
enfin qu'est-ce qu'il a généré chez les
français je m'adresse à vous fabienne
martin du chat parce qu'on a
l'impression que certains vraiment ils y
ont trouvé leur compte pas tous mais
certains y ont trouvé leur compte
oui parce que finalement nous on est
dans une société où le rapport au corps
et vous beaucoup tourné vers l'extérieur
ite le corps la productivité la
performance
la mise en scène de soi le maquillage la
rythmique des journées et certains
trouvent leur compte en fait dans cette
extériorité corporelle on est poussé
vers la société et d'autres personnes
qui sont beaucoup plus pour des
questions de personnalités aux deux
cultures dans l'intériorité finalement
ont d'ailleurs du mal à être dans ses
rythmiques que nos demandes de la
société dite de la performance et en
fonction de sa construction psychique et
de son histoire et de sa culture
certains ont totalement contraire des q7
peuple du confinement comme la
possibilité de totalement débrayé de
cette injonction à la performance
corporelle d'où cette tension entre un
sentiment de liberté de pouvoir enfin
reprendre
comment dire le ses propres rythmes
intérieur se lever quand je veux trouver
du temps à pour bricoler jardiner et de
plus être dépendant des rythmes imposés
par la société donc en fonction de sa
personnalité
certains l'ont vraiment bien vécu de
enfin pouvoir se poser et retrouver ses
propres techniques intérieur les autres
tous assez sympathique c'est agréable
mais en même temps on sait très bien que
ça ne va pas durer catherine toureille
turgis c'est à dire que ce
ralentissement cette aspiration à
laquelle enfin cette seconde vers
laquelle on est tous allés au tout début
on s'est dit bon je vois le temps de
faire beaucoup de choses
on le voit bien dans le film en fait ça
ne ça ne dure pas ça ce fan très vite ce
sentiment je voulais intervenir là
dessus est ce qu on voit bien dans dans
le film c'est qu'en fait il ya des
temporalités dans le confinement
c'est à dire il ya la temporalité lune
de miel dont il ya des gens qui est
peut-être qu'ils soient parler de leurs
l'une de leurs moments de lune de miel
après il ya le moment où on s'interroge
il ya un moment où on s'interroge sur
soi et le moment aussi des deuils et le
moment
on a besoin on a besoin de lien il ya
ces personnes qui disent finalement j'ai
regardé mes albums de photos anciennes
copines je n'avais pas vu depuis
longtemps et c'est donc on voit bien
qu'il ya plusieurs temporalités dans le
conflit de mode c'est pas les mêmes
c'est à dire que peut-être que là on a
un moment lune de miel mais la réalité
c'est pas du tout ça et puis par
ailleurs ceux qui se lèvent et qui se
couche quand ils veulent moi je suis
dans le domaine de la santé en général
quand on commence à mettre un peu de
bazar dans ses routines physiologique
c'est plutôt de la prise de poids etc
c'est pas forcément bon aussi pour la
santé c'est assez avoir aussi je vous
pose la même question jean viard cette
voie là à ce goût pour le ralentissement
cette femme qui contemple les arbres
étaient au fond ce n'est pas durable
tout le monde le sait mais c'est
compliqué parce que bien sûr pas de
manière globale mais quand on regarde
les études il ya quatre millions et demi
de gens qui disent qu'ils rêvent de
changer dit je sais pas ce que ça veut
dire ça peut être changer de partenaire
quitter la ville y en a des dizaines de
billy qui quittent la ville
alors ça va durer ça va pas durer il ya
toute la question du télétravail qui est
très compliqué et lé travail à plein
temps et confiné c'est très très dur
l'idée qu'au fond on va tous peut-être
faire un ou deux jours de télétravail ça
peut mettre de la souplesse dans nos
vies prolonger le week end
enfin jeudi dont on est on est sur plein
de rupture si vous voulez alors après
voilà je crois que ça il faut il faut le
dire parce que sinon on voit pas ce qui
se passe
moi je crois que on a beaucoup changé on
va beaucoup changer mais effectivement
je vais vous dire la vérité de convives
vous pourrez vous répondre dans cinq ans
parce que pour l'instant justement il ya
eu il ya des choses qui sont qu'ils sont
invisibles ou est-ce que vous commencez
à voir des choses vous janvier avec les
outils et des sociologues pratiques
culturelles on a augmenté de 20 % les
bandes de guitare et on n'arrête pas
dire que la culture est en crise je dis
non ce qui est en crise et le spectacle
une ans on n'a jamais autant lu on n'a
jamais fait autant de musique par
exemple
donc ça vous voyez c'est dans les
maisons de chez des gens alors vous
voyez des choses comme ça donc investi
sur sa maison en gros c'est en akoun et
on a augmenté de 29 % le budget des
maisons on a construit trois cent mille
piscine donc s'il ya une partie de la
société
disons qui s'est fait un blockhaus
confortable mais il ya une autre partie
tous les gens qui vivaient du black les
serveurs de leurs pourboires toute
l'économie parallèle a disparu cela ils
sont à la soupe populaire faut aussi
voir les deux mais effectivement il ya
les deux côtés il ya ceux qui se met à
la guitare par exemple et puis on le
voit dans le film il ya ceux qui a rêvé
de chanter
et puis qui se rendre compte qu'en fait
c'est pas trop le moment il ya des actes
manqués si on peut dire catherine
torrent urgent is comment vous
l'expliquez ce décalage entre les
aspirations du début et puis finalement
la réalité ce monsieur qui dit je vais
refaire dans ma salle de bain puis
finalement je passe mes journées à faire
du jeu vidéo
oui bon d'accord ce monsieur il tombe
dans une addiction et donc effectivement
ça augmente et aussi les comportements
addictifs les comportements addictifs
c'est pour s'échapper en principe d'une
réalisé qui est intolérable
mais ce que ce soit aussi je voulais
revenir c'est qu'on dit qu'il y a il ya
la crise sanitaire
il ya la crise économique qui suit la
crise sanitaire et que quand ces deux
crises la seront traitées on a ce qu'on
appelle dans la psychologie des
catastrophes
l'impact humain qui lui prend 18 mois à
3 ans de plus pour les deuils en moi
j'ai reçu tout de suite un papier de
l'association des psychologues
américains nous a dit attention ça va
être des deuils complexe parce que les
rituels n'ont pas pu être vécue et donc
vous ajoutez coisy six mois de deuil par
rapport à ce qu'on appelle une période
de deuil normal donc je pense que on
n'en sait rien de tout ça simplement on
a des éléments et la seule chose qu'on a
à faire c'est à être présent auprès des
gens à être présent auprès de la
population
et puis si on entend des signes que la
population va mal maintenant peut pas
dire qu'on les entend pas puisqu'on est
carrément face à mme thomas tic seront
en tout cas si on regarde les chiffres
d'abc gâteries bien faut être là qu'il
faut entre quand vous dites est
là c'est rouler c'est vous les psys
parce que présent par don mais ça paraît
complètement anachronique c'est
compliqué d'être présent ce moment
justement non c'est pas c'est pas les
psys 1
c'est toute personne je veux dire le
prendre soin il est collectif
c'est chacun d'entre nous chacun dans
nos familles chaque citoyen chacun dans
nos immeubles etc
alors c'est intéressant parce que vous
fournissez une une transition toute
trouvée vers le deuxième thème que je
voulais aborder qui est valable manière
dont ça change nos relations dans un peu
changé la la société française parce que
comment on va s'y prendre justement pour
renouer du lien j'aurais juste qu'on
regarde un extrait en fait la toute fin
du film vous allez tout de suite voir la
fin de ce film un témoignage qui est
intéressant on va en parler juste après
on a eu de l'invention s'est dit tiens
on va faire des zooms on a on a fait du
sport en y
on a fait ce qu'on a pu on a essayé de
maintenir le lien on a on a parlé avec
nos grands-parents pas par zoom et tout
mais dès qu'on a pu on est allé parce
que tu peux pas remplacer la petite main
qui se posent moi je le vois dans la
justice on ne peut pas remplacer la
petite main sur l'épaule du client quand
voilà quand il va sans s'avancer près du
juge ou quand il attend la sentence
c'est pas possible voilà ça ça manque le
toucher plus que le voir c'est vraiment
pas pouvoir toucher l'autre quoi ça
c'est compliqué mais je pense que on
reviendra dans le toucher
on serait embrassera il c'est nécessaire
alors là je me tourne vers vous fabienne
martin fischer je rappelle que voilà
vous êtes chercheur en communication
corporelle émotionnel qu'est ce qui nous
manque quand on peut pas comme ça se
toucher et puis deuxième question est-ce
que c'est aussi sûr que ça que le dit
cette dame est ce que vraiment on va
revenir vers les mêmes rituels entre
nous alors ce qui est sûr c'est que j'ai
trouvé très émouvant quand elle a dit
qu'elle avait besoin de toucher ses
clients et c'est vrai que l'essentiel de
notre relation émotionnelle passe par le
corps l'engagement le désir de montrer à
l'autre qu'on est avec lui
la sympathie d'empathie c'est une
relation corporelle et on a besoin au
quotidien et surtout dans le travail
donc si les restes les gestes barrière
perdure il faudra trouver des solutions
pour que corporellement puissent quand
même continuer à transmettre ces codes
émotionnel alors c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup parlé heureusement il reste le
regard on peut plus sourire mais on
utilise les gestes le langage donc mais
quand même c'est vrai que là la relation
corporelle et quelque chose en fait qui
qui qui sent le lien haut niveau au
niveau humain et il va faire qu'on
retrouve ça donc il ya quand même des
techniques du corps qui nous permettent
en fait de mettre en scène cette
relation affective sans nécessairement
touché physiquement on peut toucher
l'autre sans nécessairement le toucher
physiquement mais c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'on a peut-être jean viard
on sait tous ce qui ad des grands
parents qui depuis un an n'ont pas pu
embrasser leur leurs petits enfants ça a
des conséquences sociales ça bien sûr et
puis à tous les deuils qui aurait été
fait de façon catastrophique et puis
souvent c'étaient les petits enfants qui
voulaient pas venir ils nous disaient
mais toi tu as soixante dix ans j'ai un
plâtre embrasser c'est à dire qu'on a
été mis de côté nous les projets un peu
plus de 70 ans
on a été mis de côté si vous voulez
parce qu'il fait par mesure d'amour je
dirais par un amour qui nous rejeter
d'une certaine façon ce qui est pas
complètement évident moi je crois qu'on
est l'espace une espèce extrêmement pas
pouilleuse et que je dire on a besoin de
se coucher au nahd à se câliner
mais après les rituels change regardez
ça fait très longtemps que les filles
s'embrassent fait très longtemps que les
filles et les garçons s'embrassent
mais depuis quelques années les garçons
sont mis à s'embrasser moi quand j'étais
jeune jamais en leurs embrasser un
copain je vais regarder de travers en
plus à l'époque donc les rapports
homosexuels étaient très décrié sort
était mal vu mais aujourd'hui le nombre
de genres je me suis mis à embrasser des
collègues de travail des camarades
politiques je veux dire oui c'est pour
dire les rituels ils vont changer mais
il en fait ils sont pas si simples
on croit peut-être ajouter les choses
paul cassia là dessus non tout à l'heure
jean viard disait que heureusement qu'on
avait internet pendant le confinement
c'est vrai que ça nous a toutes et tous
beaucoup aidé mais c'est aussi un piège
puisque puisqu'on à cette soupape mais
on peut rester confiné à peut-être un
peu plus longtemps que ce qu'il aurait
fallu
moi je pense à la situation de nos
étudiants par exemple qui ont été
confinés qui le demeure pour une large
part et qui par conséquent ne peuvent
plus se rendre dans ces lieux de
socialisation que sont les universités
alors c'est vrai qu'on peut faire des
cours par zoom et nous sommes quatre
universitaires ici nous pouvons
parfaitement faire des cours par zoom
j'ai je crois que il n'ya pas et les
cours par zoom
au bout d'un moment montrent leurs
limites c'est vrai que la transmission
du savoir ne se fait pas de la même
manière et aussi la circonstance que les
étudiants les étudiants ne puissent pas
se rendre dans les universités vient
amputer une partie de ce qui fait le
charme des études des études super donc
là il ya un danger je crois dans cette
perte de
de relation qui a été consécutive au
confinement sa re ça rejoint ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure 4 int voitures
gisent sur l'importance des liens mais
des liens physiques dans dans la
construction même de chaque individu
c'est très important d'être physiquement
en contact on le voit physiquement en
contact et puis surtout parce où il ya
beaucoup de choses donc on peut pas
faire parce qu'en fait si on parle enfin
moi de moi mes liens avec mes étudiants
c'est autant à la cafétaria dans le
couloir et ses atouts ses liens
informels justement où on peut c'est là
que se gère les mini conflit les
confrontations et c est là bas par zoom
il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on ne peut
pas faire et de là dessus d'ailleurs
c'est intéressant de vous entendre
fabienne martin du chat vous êtes à
distance vous êtes spécialiste de la
communication corporelle qu'est ce qui
ne passe pas là entre nous à distance
qui passerait si vous étiez à la place
de paul cassia dans ce studio
et bien c'est tout les micros des micros
adaptation qui sont la plupart du temps
invisible il ya un travail comment dire
corporelle décolonisation nous sommes
des mammifères et quand on est à côté de
quelqu'un on se synchronise et il ya une
sorte de compréhension de l'autre qui
passe pas uniquement par le verbal et et
c'est difficile de complètement
comprendre quelqu'un est de connaître et
s'adapter s'ajuster à distance dont
quelque chose qui manque et c'est pour
cette raison que les nouvelles relations
professionnelles sont difficiles à
construire uniquement en sous main quand
on arrive à travailler avec quelqu'un
qu'on connaît au préalable et qu'on a
déjà vu physiquement mais construire des
nouvelles relations avec quelqu'un qu'on
n'a jamais vus automatiquement ça sera
très limité en terme d'engagement ce qui
se joue quelque chose dans le non verbal
que côté on apprend par des cotisations
de synchronisme de synchronicité des
rythmes en fait un essai physique et ça
c'est le passé face et ça ça ne peut pas
être remplacé par une relation à
distance par écran interposé
la relation c'est comme le vélo ça peut
pas s'apprendre en fait sur un écran
j'aime bien cette comparaison et j'ai
l'impression qu'elle vous fait qu'elle
vous fait sourire jean viard vous
souscrivez à ce qu'il vient d'être
d'être dit ya des choses qu'on peut pas
remplacer la question c'était
aussi est ce que est ce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont détruites pendant cette
épidémie et d effet de cliquet
finalement dans la société il ya des
choses dans lesquelles on ne reviendra
pas je ne sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est
que ce qui vient d'être dit ray
fondamentale si vous voulez mais ce qui
est vrai aussi c'est qu'une fois qu'on
se connaît on peut communiquer par humo
par internet
donc ce qui si vous laissez ça va
changer parce qu'au fond le lien
numérique est devenu premier la
prochaine fois qu'on voudra faire une
émission mettant clairement des miss a
terminé on dire à ta en fait un zoom tu
veux vraiment que nantes à paris et donc
si vous voulez de temps en temps il
faudra y aller évidemment mais je pense
que le lien entre le rouge tiré le lien
essence qui était le lien depuis la
guerre des camps se déplace dans des
pompes somme de l'essence qui a gagné
après 45
il me semble que le lien numérique est
quand même gagné mais effectivement il
n'est qu'un prolongement du lien
physique parce qu'on a besoin de ce gris
si vous voulez c'est comme les races
clauses dudit sur les étudiants il ya
tout le gris c'est ce qu'on appelle le
moment de la machine à café mais souvent
c'est que j'ai comme un colloque c'est
dans le couloir que ça se passe donc
signer ça se grille là ce temps gris
c'est vital en réalité mais après on
peut avoir un côté des liens numérique
en complément en projection un catherine
thaumaturgie spoliés je pense que c'est
important aussi que de dire qu'il y à
des personnes notamment des personnages
et puis 90 ans il ya aussi des
adolescents qui sont pas encore des
confiné c'est à dire qu'ils n'ont pas
réussi à reprendre à sortir à sortir de
chez eux et on appelle le syndrome de la
cabane danse et ça c'est le voleur le
désir de rester chez soi on n'a pas mis
tous salades crus mais pour pourquoi pas
mais l'idée c'est que là aussi on fait
il ya des choses à faire
les personnes qui sont isolées oui donc
il ya quand même je crois deux millions
et demi de personnes depuis 75 ans qui
sont isolées avis ne sont pas sortie de
chez elle et ça fait un an
ça me permet de rebondir je voudrais
alerter sur les dangers du confinement
dans le reportage il y à une dame qui
dit si on a peur de tout on ne fait plus
rien et elle ajoute à la télé ils nous
font peur
il faut entendre ce discours on ne peut
pas vivre dans une société où la
sécurité sanitaire
harrah's tous les autres droits et
libertés fondamentaux c'est une société
où qui émeut centile et dangereuse qui
est destructrice en réalité donc le
confinant nous l'avons acceptée comme un
pis-aller
ça ne peut pas être un mode de gestion
de la catastrophe sanitaire récurrents
ça fait un an que ça dure on n'en voit
pas le bout il y à des risques qui vient
d'être évoquée par les trois autres
invités qui sont très forts et qui
devrait alerter sur finalement les
effets collatéraux négatifs très
important de ce type de gestion du
risque sanitaire il ya notamment juste
un mot peut-être parce qu'évidemment
dans ce documentaire on n'en parle pas
parce que quand on va chez le coiffeur
on parle pas des problèmes
éventuellement de deux couples ou des
violences intrafamiliales mais il ya des
risques psychosociaux évidemment qui
sont liées au confinement ou là on l'a
observé sa quatrième tour et turgis ce
non seulement l'observer mais c'est noté
partout cette augmentation de 30% des
violences donc conjugale maltraitance en
revanche enfants plus de 20% rappeler
aussi que les personnes de 90 ans le
zoom et le téléphone et tout ça ça
marche parce que souvent on a un
problème de surdité après 90 ans donc
faut aussi mettre des choses sur eux il
faut vraiment une car des choses il ya
et un point intéressant dans le film sur
lequel je voulais vous entendre paul
cassia c'est le rapport des français à
la règle commune
parce qu'on voit bien en tout cas au
début que les français ont été
relativement d'odos il il ya pas eu de
rébellion ça voulait tout ça mais pas du
tout le principe chez chez nous en
france et l'application de la règle de
droit
il y à un lieu commun qui a été
véhiculée par les pouvoirs publics et
par les mini
l'intérieur successifs en particulier
qui est scandaleux qui est de dire que
les français ne respecterait pas la
règle de droit et il y a eu et nous
dit-on 21 millions de contrôles
policiers sur le terrain de
l'application du confinement mais les
français sont parfaitement capables de
respecter des mesures sanitaires sans la
menace d'une sanction pénale d'une
amende de 135 euros
je crois qu'il est temps de faire
confiance à la collectivité dans son
ensemble et de ne pas agiter en
permanence la menace de la sanction
pénale
là-dessus jean viard ça vous étonne
cette forme de docilité con qu'on
observe dans le dans le film mais qu'on
a tous observés en fait autour de nous
cette règle on l'a on l'a accepté et
puis on est gamin très très nombreux au
départ à avoir rempli les attestations
de déplacement oui mais il ya aussi
qu'on a peur on a d'ailleurs autant peur
d'être malade que transmettent la
maladie aux autres s'ils voulaient
notamment plus âgés donc je pense qu'il
ya la question de la peur parce que et
ce qui est très curieux d'ailleurs c'est
comme le président de la république
augmente en confiance chez les jeunes où
il a 62 % ce qui est énorme et dans les
milieux populaires c'est-à-dire qu'on
pourrait penser l' inverse pour aider
aux normes et à l'envié c'est plus
compliqué parce qu'à un moment on est on
se sent protégée y compris par
l'invention du vaccin et par le fait
qu'à des règles qui sont contraignantes
qui nous gâchent la vie c'est tout à
fait évident mais en même temps il ya
des règles or la société d'hier on avait
l'impression qu'ils avaient plus de
rayonnement des réalisations sans limite
on n'y comprenait rien les gens étaient
massivement populiste et donc c'est ça
qui est très curieux c'est que ces
règles au fond elle sécurise aussi c'est
ça qui est dangereux vous savez je crois
que le totalitarisme qui est beaucoup
fréquenté les pays communistes à une
époque comme gdt bakker travel le
totalitarisme ça peut créer du confort
donc pour faire très attention à cette
contrainte sur la règle on peut y
prendre
je n'ai petit pas plaisir mais on peut y
faire cocooning dedans et comme on
disait en tchécoslovaquie
même quand on est deux on est en danger
je ne suis en sécurité qu'avec ma vodka
c'est ce qui est intéressant ce que dit
jean pierre c'est que c'est très présent
dans le film ça le fait que beaucoup de
témoins beaucoup des personnages
semblent s'accommoder des privations de
liberté c'est assez commun ça oui c'est
d'autant plus commun que ça a été décrit
il y a cinq cents ans de cela par la
boétie dans le discours de la servitude
volontaire
donc c'est cette espèce de confort dans
l'asservissement individuel et collectif
que l'on peut connaître et j'ai été très
frappé par tous ces témoignages
individuels ou
fait sa salle de bain on s'occupe un peu
de soi on joue aux échecs ont refait de
la guitare c'est très très bien mais il
faut aussi penser collectif c'est-à-dire
ceux réalisés quelles peuvent être les
effets de la privation de la liberté
d'aller et de venir 23 heures sur 24
pendant une très longue période si vous
écoutiez habituel heures vous avez peur
de l'effet de cliquet celle qu'on
revienne pas en arrière de ce point de
vue là du point de vue du droit
ah oui tout à fait il faut quand même
souligner qu'on a eu un déconfinement
les plus strictes d'europe
personne n'a eu comme nous en tout cas
lors de premiers confinement cette
interdiction de sortie 23 heures sur 24
avec attestation moto attestation les
gendarmes peuvent venir frapper à votre
porte pour s'assurer que vous avez pas
reçus vos voisins ce qui n'est pas le
cas en france oui ça c'est maintenant
mais je parle en mars et est donc on
avait un déconfinement les plus strictes
d'europe qui était je crois aussi sur
l'idée que ben nous ne respecterions pas
des précautions sanitaires élémentaires
or ça me semble tout à fait inexact je
vous voyais tout à l'heure catherine
toiture liste vous sembliez vouloir
réagir à ce que je suis dans le monde
médical donc on sait que le confinement
c'est un traitement d'accord les
traitements en principe la compliance au
traitement l'observance des traitements
c'est 50%
le confinement les gens ils respectés à
84% c'est énorme en terme et c'était un
traitement en fait c'était un traitement
pour la population générale
et puis ne pas oublier que derrière tout
ça c'est la peur de la mort fabien marne
oublie ce terme et c'est fabienne martin
du chat oui je pense que c'est important
aussi de signifier que les règles ont
été respectées dans l'espace public
mais cette cette imposition corporal du
respect des règles dans l'espace public
fait que dans l'espace privé
il sait jouer des choses dans l'interdît
donc beaucoup de fêtes clandestines
beaucoup d'organisation familiale
interdite
et c'est là où il ya eu beaucoup de
contamination donc la difficulté au
niveau sociétal c'est d'équilibrer la
question de la contrainte et la
privation de liberté mais en même temps
pas trop fortement parce que sinon on a
un effet rebond
ce qui fait que du coup dans l'espace
privé les gens ne respectent pas les
règles et pour des questions justement
de aussi de sueur de surcharge
émotionnelle il ya de la violence dans
l'espace privé
donc cette question de l'équilibré entre
l'espace privé et l'espace public
il est quand même essentiel et c'est
vrai que notre mot dernier
c était quand même dans une liberté à la
fois espace public espace privé alors on
est dans des sujets très finalement très
politique depuis quelques minutes ça
tombe bien parce que j'aimerais vraiment
qu'on parle des conséquences politiques
de ce confinement de cette longue
période et sur la longue durée dans le
film on voit bien quelques uns des
protagonistes qui critiquent le système
le monde ultralibéral qui vous parliez
tout à l'heure jean viard de c2c
français qui voulaient changer leur vie
là ils veulent entre guillemets changer
la vie comme disait un un candidat à la
présidence de la république
c'est marginal south et cette volonté un
peu ce désir un peu révolutionnaire
moi il me semble que ça va être une
force il va y avoir une vague si vous
voulez mais c'est à dire les jets au
moins un briquet choses bougent mais
alors ça peut dire des choses très
contradictoires
je pense que la question si rodez
l'hégémonie pour le dire d'un terme
technique des chaînes de valeur qui
depuis 50 ans nous gouvernent
en gros quand on a vu les masques quand
on pense qu'on a dépensé 6 milliards
pour amener les bases de chine alors sa
voix ou deux centimes
c'est à dire qu'à un moment où on devait
gagner un centième de centimes sur un
match mais la chaîne de valeur était la
seule valeur légale on pouvait pas aller
contre quand vous disais mais vous
n'êtes pas dans le coup tu comprends
rien le monde moderne c'est comme ça et
les milieux populaires se sont senti
totalement des protégés moi je pense que
sur des choses comme ça on ira plus
aussi loin on va avoir une nouvelle
réflexion sur les frontières vous savez
on s'est sorti de cette période avec
deux mots coopération et frontières et
je pense qu'au niveau individuel ou leur
première frontière c'est le masque
évidemment on a enlevé le sourire mais
je pense que beaucoup opérations et
frontières ça va certainement deux deux
idées qui vont restructurer qui peuvent
des rares structures et nos sociétés si
les politiques les saisissent et je
m'arrête là dessus mais si vous voulez
on pourrait dire que les la diligence
est passé devant les chevaux dans la
descente
vous savez les politiques ils arrêtent à
vouloir tirer les sociétés jour est fort
il faut réformer sita et là d'un coup la
société a beaucoup plus changé que la
culture politique et de la haute
administration
est-ce que j'ai très peur c'est qu'ils
soient pas à la hauteur au fond des
attentes des gens et est ce que ce
décalage peut générer voilà un coup de
pression sur la sueur
dans la sphère sociale peut-être
là-dessus fabienne martin fischer est ce
qu'au fond il faut pas craindre des
comportements irrationnels violent une
sorte de france cocotte minute dans dans
les mois qui viennent dans les semaines
qui auront suivi l'éventuelle
déconfinement c'est vrai que c'est
confinement le la sur sollicitation
numérique
cette invasion d'émotion qui nous
appartiennent pas automatiquement à un
moment donné génère de la violence et
des comportements irrationnels
donc on voit bien comment au niveau
social il ya des viralité sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont non
maîtrisables des comportements dans
l'espace public que ce soit au niveau
routier des comportements à risque que
ces routes par exemple on observe déjà
un peu plus d'agressivité chez les
conducteurs
oui tout à fait voilà parce que la
voiture devient alors ça c'est un grand
classique
ma collègue psychologue pour elle
expliqué la voiture c'est un espace où
on est totalement protégée et on peut
justement se lâcher sur son désir de
contrôler le monde et d'être plus
puissant que par rapport aux autres
donc c'est pour cette quête de raison
actuellement en voiture c'est vrai que
les comportements sont souvent dangereux
même en vélo ou en trottinette
donc ça c'est caractéristique d'un
collectif qui est sous pression au
niveau corporel et émotionnelle vous d'y
ajouter un mot catherine toiture jce
rapidement ce que vivent ces deux d'un
côté si vous voulez la révolution mais
de l'autre côté la détresse c'est à dire
ce sens en ce moment les personnes les
plus vulnérables qui n'ont même pas la
force de résister de se battre et d'être
entendu vous dire qu'il ya une partie de
la société de crack littéraire
évidemment une urne à une crise de
vulnérabilité en tout cas c'est
peut-être parce que je travaille dans le
domaine donc il ya un biais en même
temps le on est en train d'adopter une
loi qui s'appelle loi sur la sécurité
globale en plein état d'urgence
sanitaire
je ne suis pas sûr que c'était le bon
moment mais cette loi elle laisse penser
que ben voilà lorsque nous nous des
coffrets non progressivement pour éviter
qu'il y ait ces mouvements populaires
tels qu'on les a connus il ya deux ans
les pouvoirs publics sont en train de
policiers arisée la société vrai juste
terminée sur un point avec vous jean
viard et très rapidement on a entendu
aussi dans le film au delà
de cet argument de révolte contre le
système
une impression des classements vous
parliez de la chanson de jean ferrat ma
france voilà on entendait des gens qui
disaient voilà tout ça c'est plus ma
france et dire qu'on était la sixième
puissance du monde
c'est très puissant ça sentiment chez
les français aujourd'hui on n'a pas été
très bon on va payer vos débuts comment
s'est payé la tête d'abord des chinois
après on s'est payé datait des italiens
bien évidemment les italiens marqué
rouler c'est normal qu'ils soient tous
malades
et puis après on s'est vu que les
allemands étaient meilleurs que nous
nous qui avions le meilleur système de
santé du monde c'est tout le monde le
sait vous rendez compte à quel point on
a été à nos propres yeux je dirais
quelque part c'est positif au sens sur
l'ennemi au niveau on est alors qu'on
avait un peu naissons croyez qu'on était
en haut de l'échelle et on est à mi
hauteur
mais si vous voulez c'est sûr qu'il ya
un décroissement et qu'il ya est
d'ailleurs un problème de fer france et
de retrouver la fierté et je crois qu'on
a besoin de fierté parce qu'on n'a pas
été très fière d'elle encore les vaccins
là excusez moi c'est un peu lamentable
alors je critique pas les pouvoirs est
ce que j'aurais pu mettre à leur place
mais n'empêche nous enfumer sur les
masques franchement et on a vu
l'appareil d'état excusez moi mais le
ministère de la santé c'est le bureau
crassier incroyable forcément on a
besoin de fierté et comment on va
retrouver de la fierté sans passer par
un parti totalitaire en fait je ne sais
pas très bien écouter on va se dire on
va s'arrêter là parce qu'évidemment vous
ouvrez un champ de réflexion sur lequel
on pourrait encore discuté pendant de
longues longues minutes mais l'émission
s'achève je voulais vous remercier
chacun et chacune de nous avoir éclairé
sur cette période voilà d'avoir relu
avec nous et avec ces français clients
natale en coiffure cette période de
confinement tellement particulière merci
à tous les cas je renvoie à votre livre
jean viard à la page blanche voilà
réflexion notamment à la suite de cette
période
paru l'an dernier aux éditions de l'aube
je renvoie également fabienne martin du
chat à votre livre laventure du corps la
communication corporelle une voie vers
l'émancipation paru aux presses
universitaires de grenoble
merci à chacun et à chacune de nous
avoir suivi et à très bientôt sur public
sénat
[Musique]